like how do you get the supposed silent
majority to be the vocal majority you've
done I've been asking myself everyday to
him people keep saying the silent
majority will speak up in November and
Trump will win and the Republicans will
win yeah maybe maybe they will or maybe
they're it doesn't matter whether or not
there's a silent majority at all
whoo-hoo I can't member who said this I
think it may have been Michael malice
I'm probably crediting the wrong person
if maybe it was Jesse Kelly oh whatever
I'm shouting you guys out so I don't
know who said it they said if a tree
falls in the forest and no one's around
to hear it did it make it sound No
so if there is a silent majority and
they're silent they may as well not
exist it makes it sound good tree yep
but no one hears it that's okay so no
one knows no one cares no action is
taken the tree is never removed there
you just have a downed tree and you have
the problems caused by a downed tree so
if you have a silent majority and they
say nothing they may as well not exist
Greg Gutfeld
was it Greg yeah yeah I started out the
wrong people
Greg good tweet and I commented to it I
just added a bunch of people whatever it
was you know it's like it's always one
of them they make good points right they
do yeah so the way I see it is we've you
know what I was thinking earlier I was
like you know what I think I think we
lost a long time ago I think so sunsoo
out of war no you win the war I disagree
for going to war bro we just we've been
watching across the country sure people
being charged like a cop being he's
facing the death penalty for doing his
job and there's no protest no riot no
one's speaking up look I say no one I'm
being I'm exaggerating of course there
are some people speaking of there's no
collective organizations the blue flu in
Atlanta was only like a hundred and
something off it was over 300 people are
you sure in Atlanta just oh no in LA no
no in Atlanta over Rashad Brooks it was
like 150 okay they gotta have more cops
than that in Atlanta even the cops don't
stand up for each other
which is surprising in New York there's
been a you know a little bit of a blue
flu Li had a blue flu but these are
jurisdictions with tens of thousands of
police officers and support staff they
don't stand up they don't speak up
nobody cares the look man how do you
have for I think it was 19 days these
people were dancing
on the highway and the cops did arrest
any of them they're allowed to do this
they're allowed to break the kovat rules
they're allowed to break CDC regulations
you're not gonna convince me I'm not
trying to convince any I'm plain hurt
yeah I don't like I don't like
complaining I'm sick of people
complaining like I I want to work on
with the answer the the what we need to
do what do we need to do I get it I get
it
that they're there that's why I keep
saying like they're firing on all cinder
cylinders they're trying their hardest
right now because they are losing the
power that they've been used to for so
long what power the power to control the
masses the power to do what they really
feel like that this is them unleashing
the Beast the Beast to try to reclaim
the control that they are clearly
fighting for what what what when do they
lose it they've been controlling
cultural institutions forever they
haven't lost it I'm saying yeah grip is
loosening its they're seeing it that's
why they hate Trump so much but what if
their grips realize it look when the
table on because it's getting worse and
worse
Trump's finally canceling China
basically it's like yes he spoke about
China for a long time but all of a
sudden it's you know that doesn't change
their control of cultural institutions
which dictate our politics three four
years later okay if they are getting
away with breaking the law and the
states and the police and the DA's are
all supporting it and all the major
corporations are supporting their their
religion then then what it doesn't
matter if Trump does anything to China
it doesn't even matter if Trump wins
because it in four years you're not
reversing two decades of of
indoctrination well we're not seeing it
because number one the media isn't gonna
want anyone to see this all right I'm
hearing stories that Sheriff departments
are like we're not wearing masks we're
not enforcing this mask law anymore and
it's it's happening I mean I'm seeing
little Inklings of it because it filters
out people are like yo check this out
this is actually happening and I look
into it and it's true so there's places
out there that they are standing up you
know cities then yeah absolutely it's
cities and who controls the cities the
Democrats they want this to go on there
that's why they're using this guy as an
example they're like oh man we got to
give them the 1.2 million dollar
that's obscene absolutely Truitt us they
wanna they've taken it up to 11 and
they're they're pushing on everyone
trying to convince the the rest of us
like they're convincing you you just
told me I I don't think we're gonna win
I think we've get I think we already
lost I think we've already lost even
worse yeah and worse yep they got you
well they didn't get me I am got me got
me in what regard though they've
convinced you that you've lost and what
is that what does it accomplish for them
you give you're gonna give up you're
gonna go live down by the river and I'm
gonna take over the show no work we're
moving to the middle of nowhere to get
out of the cities I know I'm just making
up okay I'm kind of making a joke but
I'm also you just basically said that
though so it's like I'm not gonna be
convinced that they're gonna take over
our country no I'm not absolutely not
I'm gonna I'm gonna keep doing my
research every day I do hours of
research I'm learning how we got to this
point I'm learning two laws that we have
right now I want to know all this stuff
that I can so that I could talk about it
and it had figured out because I just
said I don't like complaining I don't
like complaining I don't like people
that complain I want to talk about the
solutions I want to I want to work on
how to move forward
what's the solution well really if I had
that you think I would I wouldn't have
led with that if I had what solution
already give me an idea of what you
think we do now more people need to do
exactly what I'm doing right now do
their research open their eyes look
what's actually happening that's what
needs to happen and then what what do
you mean yeah how do they apply it like
just in voting man I wish I had all the
answers yeah I wish I had all the
answers too well I am NOT gonna give up
no way give up in what regard though
much what roll over and and let them win
let them take up and destroy our history
let them tell me that you know this
country isn't great anymore like that
we're not like on the forefront of
showing the world what it's like to be
free what would inspire the silent
majority to all at the same time go out
in the streets and March in the hundreds
of thousands
that's a great question it's a great
question Tim I don't think anything all
right I think there's there's there's a
couple big problems with the hyper
concentration of the progressive left in
cities
they have to do is walk out their front
door and they find thousands of people
who agree with them for conservatives
and moderates you live in the suburbs
you live in the rural areas you're miles
away from the next person you'd all have
to fly to one city to be seen so this is
an interesting thing about Donald
Trump's inauguration and they mocked him
over it saying that nobody showed up
well Trump's got a huge rural voter base
they're not all gonna fly to DC they're
gonna watch online so based on the
online livestream numbers he had a
really large inauguration viewership if
brand marketing big business has already
been infiltrated by the far left I guess
they just they just shift their that
whatever mask they're wearing to keep
keep people buying spending all their
money on the stuff they don't need that
exactly what it PayPal will will ban you
out right if you have bad opinions and
they and they control I think like 76 or
78 percent of all financial transactions
online some ridiculous number next up is
stripe other than that there's like
basically nothing and stripe has the
same rules same rules makes me not want
to use get Palin do you see what
happened you know what happened with
with the gab what about it I think it
was gab Google sees there don't make
their domain name right look at that gap
I think I think so I think it was gab
maybe that was the daily stormer gab had
right now tor by the guy who founded gab
has been banned from credit card
companies I said no no I think it's just
visa okay and anybody who who is like
associated with him write his address
mm-hmm can't use visa anymore okay what
happens if Visa and MasterCard ban you
and they have done this already one guy
what his name is I think Robert Spencer
that the guy oh the the jihad Reese yeah
he's a well-known researcher not Richard
Spencer not Richard his name is Robert
Spencer
and apparently MasterCard contacted
patreon and said terminate his income
and patron said you got it and then one
day he woke up and all of his income for
his business was gone
Chase Bank banned the Andrey qatari oh
the guy with a chairman of the of the
proud boys they terminated his personal
accounts
okay because a journalist called
contacted them and said that he was you
know far-right or whatever so these
companies these financial institutions
already have the rules in place and they
will ban you if you get out of line you
will not be able to use a credit card
you will not be able to open a bank
account it's happened these people are
gone and no one's done anything and
that's it there's gone like their their
businesses were destroyed they they're
no longer in the in the public realm and
it keeps happening and it's been getting
worse and now we've graduate to the next
level where these people of this
ideology can willfully break the law on
federal property and no one charges them
with a crime so what so what do we do
ten what is the answer huh are you gonna
give up are you gonna are you gonna stop
speaking out you're gonna go live down
by the river half we literally are going
to live that's funny I'm 22 laugh at but
I'm actually I'm serious like what do
you what I'm not I'm not kidding when I
say halfway they're getting away from
the cities getting out of New Jersey I
did I tell you I know a lot of people
who have fled the cities in New York
five hundred thousand middle class and
wealthy people have fled the cities
already you know employment so maybe
that will strip their power away maybe
that's a big move that will take the
power away from these of these
institutions there's also the argument
that a major flood of progressive
leftists into rural areas will overwhelm
the rural areas and then it will
fracture the electoral college and then
give the intersectional left the the win
from this point on hmm let me people
have already said there will never be
another Republican president after
Donald Trump yeah I think that's silly
too well the Republican Party will
change okay you know it has it has been
changing and in a good way though you
know we have to have the ability to
change that's kind of what cancer
culture is ridiculous because you know
it's like they don't allow people to
number one admit that they were wrong
doesn't matter if you were wrong you're
cancelled you're done forever you can't
change you know like Don Lemon changed
in the worst way you know yeah like he
he said some really solid stuff that
like makes sense to me anyway and you
know now he's this drone you know cuz he
conformed well not everybody's
people are seeing in there like this is
ridiculous yeah this is a drone what's
the worst-case scenario if we all just
said okay to the left I don't I don't
want to think about that that's I'm not
I'm not gonna cater to that no because
they really never do that so no I'm not
even gonna I'm not even talking about it
many of the these people who have bent
the knee to them will keep their mouths
shut and keep feeding their families and
say you know I don't care about anybody
else but myself and if I just stay quiet
keep my head down I'll get by I'll just
tell him to look at what the mayor was
doing in Seattle
go go to do it Summer of Love
ha ha ha three days later they show up
at her house she's the mayor so yeah and
think about this way okay if there's a
thousand potential targets and you stick
your head up and say hey enough it's you
if you keep your head down it's one of
the thousand you might get you might you
might get by I I'd be willing to bet
this is the problem we have with the
silent majority most most of the people
are saying why should I guarantee the
risk to myself when I can cross my
fingers and hope I don't win the lottery
I don't know ask Terry Crews he's he's
on a stage he's using his voice I'm on a
stage right now I'm using my voice I
hope I hope a lot of people are
listening to what I'm saying
and and doing their own research in fact
they're hitting me up saying thank you
we we are I'm doing research I'm seeing
what of this I used to be a Democrat I'm
no longer a Democrat because I see
what's going on in the world so I'm
using I'm doing what I can right now
yeah this is what I can do I want to see
these people were on an interstate
highway right yeah is that so so where
it where's bill bar come on lock him up
good question lock him up good question
the Hoopoe word ID what why was uh why
was Seattle having anything to do with
it if it was an interstate that's
federal when I was in during the
Ferguson protests though they organized
an interstate protest and they were
specifically warned by the organizers
that it was interstate is federal
jurisdiction which means if you get
arrested you are not going to a local
county station you're gonna be taken by
the feds and the feds never lose that's
right so they were like keep that in
mind if you
choose to do this why why is you know
you know maybe maybe the idea among but
maybe there's two scenarios Trump is
disorganized and not paying attention
you got other things to worry about and
so no one's going after these protesters
who keep doing this I think the
president's paying attention then maybe
they're ignoring it on purpose because
it makes people like me angry really
angry yeah and then it makes people like
me really angry too and then I guess I'm
just going about it a little differently
than you are I want to know when it
comes to November if I have a choice
between Biden which is obviously a no
and Trump but Trump has the ability to
start arresting these people in federal
highways why he didn't do it why why he
deserves my vote I like the Garden of
Heroes that's a good rebuttal I like
that he's actually sent out DHS and FPS
to go start arresting some of these
people who are destroying things on
federal property I mean that that's like
being mad at him for for killing a
hundred thousand people because of kovat
it's like you you think that the
President of the United States can can
handle being the president doing I don't
know I've never been the president I
don't know what what kind of what
entails that job the amount of stuff
that they have to do knowing exactly
what's going on dolphin with every
single country you know all around it
the the pressures probably immense no
wonder he goes golfing
it's like I like golf and I've been
golfing so hit it you think he could
lean over to someone and say I want you
to go talk to you know bar or someone at
the DOJ and I want these people
prosecuted you can't do that there's
there's I know when when to when I know
something and I know when I don't know
something it's like I have never been in
that position I could never understand
the pressure that he is in I won't
pretend to know so I want tangibles okay
I will not simply be like well I guess
I'll vote for Trump if he's not doing
anything for me well we're not we have
no idea what his platform is yet like
they he's waiting for the DNC to tell
everyone that Hillary's running instead
of button is that yeah Hillary's gotta
run yeah take over for Biden she said it
today that she would probably beat Trump
well it was Friday right yeah Ron said
that she would beat him in November and
that's maybe what they're waiting for
they're waiting for something to happen
because Biden's gonna drop out but
here's what I can say people are like
admit it you're gonna vote for Trump or
whatever and I said leaning towards
probably if it was today we'll see what
happens okay and that's because for one
garden of heroes awesome I love it I
literally love it it's incredible
beautiful everyone agrees yeah they
don't which is stupid because they
should definitely should I don't get it
department of homeland security
protecting statues I like it
fantastic me too excellent job and I
want to see when they have the power to
actually arrest these people are you
leaving the wh oh great great idea dad I
don't know about I think so I think
there's a lot of problems and I think
Trump might be pulling a big ask I think
China and the w-h-o are working hand in
hand and then China dumped in two
billion dollars when Trump said we
wouldn't fund you in general don't worry
about it here's two billion yeah because
yeah we've been mm-hmm it's another mask
isn't it I think thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you